alright let's get on with this all right
let's go final final peak this mountains
really piqued my achay Wow oh oh we have
to go make a claim
cap hey Seb it is a sunny day it's
gorgeous we should hike up a mountain
stretch those legs and you know when
work on our guns abs those glutes yeah
big butts man's all the way I think
we've already established that we're
excellent Mountaineers so how about we
engage in what we call the three peaks
challenge I love it we have to find the
three highest points in Los Angeles okay
and I guess go by foot by bike and buy a
motorbike can we can we go and change
yeah let's get dressed for climbing all
right so we're ready let's walk oh we
hike hike yes still got it so this is
the road oh that was nice thanks if we
can find T quad bikes I'll do so said we
really need two of the same thing yeah
we're gonna make this a fair race all
right let's get let's get to full bikes
i think that ok well let's just see what
we come across next let's browse this
shopping aisle yeah which is what is
fair city Japan Oh Sam I'm ready for
climbing are you yeah let's go climbing
tuned as well let's go hiking all right
you go I'll follow face of the first
peak three two one yeah there's the
worst non straight line styles try to
stop you here Oh hatin Oh Lord haha
missa Christ what are you doing dying
okay to the pipes scraps achill yes ah
man I didn't see the pipes crud Boosh my
the weed for up oh I see the pipes Sam
I'm gonna beat you there uh I oh no no
cuz I just killed myself pretty much i'm
gonna lost my quad bike [ __ ] get away
from my quad bike Oh
not me uh what are you look a little bit
like an input killer on a on a very weak
mobility later come on it's just a dead
end oh wait I found it I found the jump
on yes oh [ __ ] that's how you doing
though that's how you do it ok so I'll
come I'll teach you I'll teach you the
ways out of hiking Oh sugar I think I
might be stuck hiking is hard yeah it's
really hard I'm [ __ ] somewhat austin
powers to enter here all right I need to
I need to physically but budge this
other way yes I rescued it is freed it
it's a saved it house oh you there often
watching this is glorious all right what
what oh you're under garlic you're under
there as my way through the ground I'm
gonna come not you just leave her there
don't you go anywhere I'm gonna try to
notice this myself I think the only way
i know to nudge Oh nailed it just later
hey what's ain't gonna happen I single I
deck no no no no no no if I use the
other core bike to wedge it out yes no
go on so what hiking's all about isn't
it getting in touch with nature I'm
really glad we got these helmets on to
protect ourselves from ourselves need
this how close what's our progress where
did you watch that's not helping I just
hit myself all the way to the end no
he'll think so this is this is not a
comfortable position for me yes yes yes
Oh Hickel matter damage be evening you
dislikes Nick I'm on mine will your well
your is moved you think yeah we totally
well cease to be too slowly grinding my
face along this bar
oh I've done it quick come save me oh
[ __ ] it's not it is it gone I tried to
move it with Billy's I'd it didn't work
sab give up ok I've got new wheels you
have to destroy the evidence though ok
maybe not you as well with it though get
out of there I love of God get out of
there I'm stuck did he know you're now
you're free I won't accept defeat that a
couple of all yes yes I made it like a
boss I don't even know how I was just
suddenly climbing on the edge oh come on
man yes yes yes let's go let's race oh
[ __ ] go go go go oh no you're no you did
oh you remembered to jump out of it just
a boy nope always fell off it was her
left do this is so close this is like
the greatest athletic severe every
visitor I'm down the other side so I
know sizes this is so delicate so I'm so
kicking your ass jump you dumb bastard
and then took down the building roof yes
victory jump oh well so if that was a
the first peak complete I believe all
right Pete goes to you yeah they lost
Davis gate was closed thanks for playing
thanks for playing this [ __ ] and there
we jump
thank you next baby I said it's time for
peak number two we got our bikes yeah
let's race to the base of the hill and
then we'll race up the hill as well
alright looking forward to 32 too late
oh you went on to I get a handicap for
losing this is my neighborhood I know
these streets like I take the baby two
monstrous I've already been take it out
thanks neighbor try to take out the
racing line hey what you want the racier
set that is the second peak that's where
we're doing I'm gonna try and get as
high up there as possible now you have
to leave the road here okay no more
roads roads are no light all right
you've gone left I'm going right I mean
the other the other way the other left
and right all right well if you ever get
to the top of a lair all right climb God
go on come on come on first one to the
top no no yeah I think you won then he
is that the peak we need to climb I
think that's the peak we need to climb
this the Hollywood Hills was just a
taster that was a warm-up that was a we
flirted with that peak that one's got a
nipple to the looks of it first row
racing to the nipple said boob mountain
all right this is the seat most serious
thing that's happened to me yet okay yo
good negotiation fast it totally bust it
all right all right a rich marriage
begins here River curses oh hahaha you
didn't boss it at all no no oh [ __ ] haha
heike why are you doing this today huh
what was that no I will I will shoot you
if you get my bike I will absolutely
shoot this gun through your head that's
what you need Jay so you just run Oh
Here I am it's doing nothing the
parachute is the victory symbol you feed
all the way up here hey I'm afraid I win
this peak as well cry sorry chilly adds
the biggest peak so if you ain't chili
at that counts double o deck didn't know
me to do that oh oh not in it no no no
no no jaani oh oh
no no God hold it together let's get a
little Katie can't believe i'm still on
the bucket land it yes me yes yes oh
hush it's the final and biggest peak oh
yeah it's huge accounts double this is
gonna be a direct hike directs oh wait i
don't know roads allied now roads okay
since we're over that bridge it's on we
must disband this on all right let's get
on with this all right let's go okay
final final peak this mountains really
piqued my issue Wow oh oh we have to go
make a claim off you get so we got a
quad bike up instead this was always the
plan all along the whole time right must
depart the road now straight up straight
up geez your muscles your engine but I
well don't go back in the water no I'm
off I'm off it Oh No pletely climbing
the wrongfully going I've died word are
sad all right used to use the downward
momentum to oh god no all right campus
yeah no I'm not all right I'm back in
the climate of all right I'm really bad
don't don't stall you really have to
slalom Al's guys I've had it run into a
tree issue which has become a my quad
bikes running down that's an issue come
back keep up stood you borrow me know
I've lost no God no lost it don't god
how's that huge game working on let's go
the road work oh I see you he's here me
hopping like a gazelle up this mountain
but I know nobody's out back is out
oh don't you know me no bike you know go
back oh oh no you better you better flip
up right huh words are gonna be hides
come on if you don't flip ah alright
alright baseball bat oh dear oh we're
here before yes the tule worked oh no no
no thanks Rocky no like you know where
the hell cam Oh cam I think you're there
are you there ham I believe oh you've
won I believe someone has arrived oh
bloody killing me all right mount
chiliad look I'm here you'll need to
look very very well here I'm praying I'm
pretty happy with that victory yeah that
was pretty good man okay all right so we
came up that side I feel like we should
race down I think we shall the second
marker for we have to get to last week
yeah cows in the water we are gonna try
to put ourselves but our quad bikes in
the what it says it's dangerous I
nonsense I think they were just the sign
was dangerous got it oh no over two
years a poster oh don't sit on it
spitting spit oh I'm dead spits I I am
still on I'm i am a dead man uh he's
tricky you did very well too sticky
there where's my outlet if if I were a
quad bike I see would I be I see a quad
bike it's nearer than my quad bike Oh No
where did your quad bike go I don't know
i'll go to that somewhere down here i'm
down here so maybe he's near me I think
my I think my bikes been erased arrays
oh no I was so close get on get I found
it up I was like I hear it said on its
mmm nothing so uh oh that's too bad
because I smell my quad bike wear it
where is what I wished uh oh dead ah
welcome to my world Sabbath totally just
found my motorbike is being returned
here what yeah it's actually my more
bike Oh
no you have you have speed on your on
your side right over this trees I'm here
sad oh I'm here the station wagon yes
hey I am in the water oh you I am like a
stitch I am a fish Oh literally fell but
I said I don't have a cigarette Lisa
these are sodden with easy water back
there is well yeah well I dropped them
in the water obviously they're gonna be
sorry okay sorry i'll just make another
one I don't have any way always do this
what if I breathe it onto your face let
me get close thank you breathing on to
me try again Oh give me give me this is
one sweet sugar catia get us our money
oh what a cap haha things have got
things have got romantica from my screen
oh here we go much better oh you still
got them another one ready to go I like
to smoke afterwards I think I think
there's any one thing left can i think
so i think we should dare go forth to
our next adventure the adventure of
death yet yeah of the afterlife
you